- [Instructor] Changing
the pH of a solution
can affect the solubility
of a slightly soluble salt.
For example, if we took some
solid lead two fluoride,
which is a white solid,
and we put it in some distilled water,
the solid is going to reach an equilibrium
with the ions in solution.
Lead two fluoride forms lead two plus ions
and fluoride anions in
a one to two mole ratio.
So if we have two lead two
plus ions in this diagram,
we need four fluoride anions.
At equilibrium, the rate of this solution
is equal to the rate of precipitation,
and therefore, the amount of solid
and the concentration of ions
in solution remains constant.
And this forms a saturated
solution of lead two fluoride.
To the system at equilibrium,
we're gonna add some H plus ions.
So by increasing the concentration
of H plus ions in solution,
we're decreasing the pH of the solution.
When the H plus ions are
added to the solution,
most of them react with
the fluoride anions
that are present.
So H plus plus F minus forms HF.
Comparing the first diagram
to the second diagram,
I just happened to add three H plus ions,
which will react with three
of the fluoride anions
that are present to produce three HF.
Notice how the concentration
of fluoride anions in solution
has decreased from the first
diagram to the second diagram,
because of the addition
of the H plus ions.
So the system was at equilibrium
and the concentration of
fluoride anions was decreased.
According to Le Chatelier's Principle,
the system will shift in the direction
that decreases the stress.
So if the stress is decreased
concentration of fluoride anions,
the system will shift to the right
to make more fluoride anions.
And when the system shifts to the right,
more lead two fluoride dissolves
to increase the
concentration of Pb two plus
and fluoride anion.
We can see that comparing
the second diagram
to the third diagram,
so the amount of solid has gotten smaller,
since some of that lead
two fluoride dissolved,
and we've increased the
concentration of Pb two plus
and F minus in solution.
The solid keeps dissolving
and the concentration of ions
keeps increasing in solution
until the system reaches equilibrium.
So for a saturated solution
of lead two fluoride at equilibrium,
decreasing the pH or making
the solution more acidic
by increasing the
concentration of H plus ions,
increases the solubility
of lead two fluoride,
which is why we saw more
of the solid dissolve
when the H plus ions were added.
This effect of decreasing the pH
and increasing the solubility
of a slightly soluble salt
happens whenever the slightly soluble salt
contains a basic anion.
For this example, the basic
anion is the fluoride anion,
which reacts with the added H plus ions.
And when the basic anion reacts,
that decreases the concentration
of that basic anion,
which caused the equilibrium
to shift to the right.
And there are many other
examples of basic anions,
two more would be the hydroxide anion
and the carbonate anion.
And if a compound contains a basic anion,
such as the hydroxide anion,
hydroxide functions as a base
and reacts with H plus ions to form H2O.
So therefore, the solubility of a compound
containing a hydroxide ion would increase
as H plus ions are added to the solution.
It's also important to note
for this lead two fluoride problem,
if the pH is decreased at
a constant temperature,
the Ksp value for PbF
two remains constant.
So the molar solubility does increase,
but the Ksp value remains the same.
This time, instead of lead two fluoride,
let's look at lead two chloride.
Lead two chloride is also a white solid.
So if we dissolve some in solution,
eventually, we would reach an equilibrium
between the solid and
the ions in solution.
So this diagram here
shows a saturated solution
of lead two chloride and the
system is at equilibrium.
And to the system at equilibrium,
we decrease the pH by adding
H plus ions to the solution.
In this case, the chloride anions
aren't basic enough to
react with the H plus ions.
Therefore, we do not form HCl
and the concentration of chloride anions
remains the same as it was
in the original diagram.
So if the concentration of
chloride ions remains the same
and the concentration
of lead two plus ions
would remain the same, the
system is still at equilibrium
and decrease in the pH had no effect
on the solubility of the solids.
So we have the same amount
of lead two chloride solid
on the bottom of the
beaker in both diagrams.
So whenever an anion has
an extremely weak base,
like the chloride anion,
we say that this is an
anion of negligible basicity
and the solubility of salts
with anions of negligible basicity
is unaffected by changes in pH.